they survived a harrowing sea Crossing
from Africa but they've been refused
entry into Italy and have been caught in
a political stalemate the Italian
government says they have to leave the
ship's crew is refusing until everyone
is allowed off
we will never leave the port as long as
there's one person on board our battle
which has the right for international
protection which has the right to reach
safe land
two rescue ships Humanity one and
geoberens arrived in the Sicilian Port
of Catania on Saturday with a total of
621 migrants only around 450 were
allowed to stay the Italian government
says they were not vulnerable and should
be repatriated to Germany and Norway
which operate the ships that carried out
the rescues the right-wing Italian Prime
Minister Giorgio Maloney pledged a
Crackdown on migrants during her
election campaign those aboard the
humanity one and geoberens are feeling
the effects of that but humanitarian
groups have started legal action against
the Italian government there was a
discrimination also in the in the moment
when someone go out of the the ship okay
we don't know how we know how this
selection was made okay and we think
that it was not as election based on
with the the right method
humanitarian organizations say that the
Italian government is clearly in breach
of the United Nations convention on
human rights and that they are confident
of winning any legal battle but that
takes time and it still leads hundreds
of migrants living in a political no
man's land
critics of the government say it is
playing political games and thousands
more migrants enter Italy under their
own means or are rescued by the Italian
Coast Guard and those saved by Foreign
ships represent only a small percentage
but the trauma for those stranded on the
ships can only get worse they have fear
in their eyes and that they are pushed
back into international waters maybe
even pushed back to Libya so all the
memories come up on that Journey what
they experienced saw people dying saw
people going missing in front of them
they don't want to go back to these
places as winter sets in and seas become
rougher one thing is certain more
migrants will need to be rescued and
more will die Sony bertley Al Jazeera
Catania Sicily